[Music]
good evening good evening
tonight i can report to the american
people and to the world
the united states has conducted an
operation that killed osama bin laden
the leader of al qaeda osama bin laden
osama bin laden osama bin laden has been
killed america's number one public enemy
was dead killed along with his
bodyguards and son it is not so safe
house in a nondescript suburb in about
about pakistan
where he'd been hiding in plain sight
for years
he was pursued by the most advanced
intelligence and counter-terrorism
operation in the world
besides bin laden's body something else
flew back with the navy seals that had
killed him
the hard drives from his computers
the seals were able to get treasure
trove for information
at the time of their seizure these were
some of the most secret materials in the
world
we know based on the letters that the 9
11 attacks were not sufficient
now these hard drives are going to be
downloaded and the most notorious
terrorist in history has his most
private thoughts revealed
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the osama bin laden the world
knows
stoic
armed
inscrutable
pictured here in a photo found on his
hard drives
but there's someone else in this picture
[Music]
me peter bergen
one of the very few westerners to meet
bin laden
i produced the first television
interview with osama bin laden in 1997.
we were given crude blindfolds heavily
armed guys from al qaeda drove us higher
and higher into the mountains
around midnight appeared osama bin laden
i i'd expected this sort of
table-thumping revolutionary you know
somebody who's super angry
he didn't come across like that he kind
of carried himself like a cleric
he was very low key he didn't raise his
voice he presented himself as this
modest guy the question is was he really
that in reality
what are your future plans
you'll see them and hear about them in
the media
god willing
[Applause]
four years later bin laden delivered on
that promise killing almost 3 000 men
women and children on 9 11.
bin laden is one of the few individuals
you can really say changed history and
i've spent much of my professional life
since the mid 90s trying to work out who
exactly he is
i thought i found out pretty much
everything there was to know about bin
laden but turns out that wasn't the case
at all
[Music]
after killing bin laden the navy seal
team recovered five computers over 100
flash drives dvds and computer disks
multiple cell phones and a handwritten
journal from bin laden's about about
compound
in 2017 the cia declassified and
released much of the contents of these
drives to the public
our whole lives are on our computers now
and i think there can be a lot of
meaning in zeros and ones
bin laden never expected these hard
drives to see the light of day so really
this is bin laden unplugged
there are over 250 gigabytes of data so
sifting through this immense amount of
files is a daunting task so i need to
enlist some expert help
so
this is all the documents the mountain
of documents give us a sense of the
scale of how much material there was the
cia they listed that they had nearly 470
000 items wow
nelly lahood is probably one of the few
people in the world who's read all the
personal communications in these drives
in the original arabic and she's writing
a book about them it's very much based
on the internal correspondence al-qaeda
secrets if you like dr reed molloy one
of the leading forensic psychologists in
the world who's consulted with the fbi
for the past two decades largely focused
on threat assessment and threat
management dalia mcgowahed an american
muslim researcher and director of
research at the institute for social
policy and understanding we do research
and education about the biggest
challenges facing the american muslim
community ali sufan an arabic speaking
former fbi special agent who was the
first to find definitive proof linking
911 to the al-qaeda leadership this is a
break
from
the hideout of osama bin laden in kabul
i get this brick to be
a reminder
of what happened on 9 11.
bin laden was a man who was pretty
careful about keeping his own secrets
but fortunately somebody at the compound
had a home video camera
the cameraman for these home videos
never shows his face but looking at this
arm it looks like the arm of a young man
which leads us to believe that it's
harley bin laden bin laden's son who
would have been in his late teens early
twenties
[Music]
this was the terrorist mastermind's lair
and what's so fascinating is this layer
seems so normal
i'd even call it boring
here we see a clip showing off the
[Music]
garden here his son helps a baby chick
hatch
[Music]
here a technical difficulty while
filming one of bin laden's speeches
[Music]
hardly the image of a terrorist
mastermind
appearances are often deceiving however
and there's more to these files than
first meets the eye
a large amount of videos were found
hundreds of propaganda videos
surprisingly a lot of american and
western movies like ice age
some japanese anime
viral video downloads like charlie bit
my finger
a reported significant amount of
pornography
and as well
the treasure trove of personal
communications
the sheer number of people living on
this compound makes it actually kind of
hard to attach
which person belongs to which particular
file there were at least 20 people
living on the compound
complicating the picture milan was using
used computers and so when the cia
recovered the files some of this
material may have been from a previous
owner for all these reasons we need to
proceed with caution about some of the
conclusions we draw from these hard
drives
but these files are still an incredible
resource one of the first questions
we're trying to unpack here is what was
life like for bin laden living here on
the compound
you live this very
very modest life i mean they were living
like medieval peasants almost
[Music]
from reading a lot of the documents that
were recovered they tried to
live a normal life
osama bin laden was in the hideout with
his family in isolation of the society
that they lived in
bin laden and his bodyguards went to
considerable length to make this a
fortified compound
there was very high wall around the
compound
and everything was about staying inside
the compound not going to school
not going shopping
they were growing their own vegetables
they were raising chickens
they had cows
[Music]
they burned their own trash
and in a sense it was a sort of a prison
of milan's own making that he
kind of checked himself into
there are a few particular files that at
first look like normal home videos
maybe bin laden's son just playing
around with the camera
[Music]
but when there's clip after clip of
zooming in on the hills around the
compound
or zooming in on the sky
or even following a helicopter
you start to realize that they might be
on guard
on the lookout for anyone who might be
looking for them
in the context of bin laden we know that
he was being pursued by the
most advanced uh intelligence and
counter-terrorism operation in the world
he knows that the whole world is looking
for him
so he was always paranoid the only way
he communicated with the real world is
through a courier
there is no phone there is no internet
there is no telecommunication wiring
that's going to the house at one time
mahmoud his chief of staff
said sheikh it's very difficult for us
to send couriers to people around the
world can we at least use email and
someone laden responded he's like what
are you talking about encryption
you want to use encryptions against
people who invented emails
absolutely not
[Music]
that means that everything we see on
these drives that can be linked to bin
laden
must have been smuggled into the
compound on usb drives
one set of files seems particularly
surprising
the cia said there was a significant
amount of pornography found on these
computer drives what do you make of that
nowhere in the letters are such
materials requested and they didn't have
internet so how could they really be
downloading it
i don't know if bin laden utilized that
pornography but if he did it wouldn't
surprise me biology trumps ideology
it's absolutely prohibited in islam and
i think most faiths and i just want to
point out one really important point
here whether or not they were watching
porn really doesn't concern me that much
because they were also killing people
and that is far more prohibited by the
quran than watching sex
we know that al qaeda used pornography
to send messages so they embed encrypted
messages in pornographic photos there
are softwares where you encrypt a
message inside a pornographic video or a
pornographic picture when you have the
code on the other side
that porn photo is suddenly a message
you don't need to encrypt messages or
use couriers if you're just planning a
quiet retirement he spent years on the
run and billam believed the best way for
him to reclaim the world stage was
either to repeat or even improve upon
what he saw as his greatest
accomplishment
the 911 attacks
what do the billions of zeros and ones
on your computer say about you
and what do they say about the most
wanted man in history
among the files found on bin laden's
hard drives a striking number of them
dealt with what he considered his
greatest accomplishment
i think everybody of a certain age
remembers exactly where they were on 9
11 2001.
[Music]
for me i was sitting at my breakfast
table getting ready to drive across
middle america to start graduate school
and i look up
and see the horrific images on tv
[Music]
to see this kind of violence
was
deeply hurtful deeply enraging
and then to
and then to find out later
that it was actually carried out in the
name of my faith
it was actually harming people way
beyond the poor victims that they
targeted it was also harming islam i
remember it was the first time in my
life that i was scared for someone to
know that i was a muslim
[Music]
the man that i had met four years
earlier had just overseen the murder of
nearly 3 000 men women and children
[Music]
what could these drives show myself and
my colleagues about the man who did this
osama bin laden's hard drives contained
both incriminating data and glimpses
into the banality of evil
the key question is which is which
watching an old al jazeera documentary
about himself probably this is one of
those
documentaries that he thought
misrepresented him he used to
monitor this
and he used to monitor it very very
seriously
he's
wondering if those glory days for him
would be something he would ever return
to
bin laden seemed to revel in replaying
his greatest hits
interesting how he's sitting there
watching satellite news
that gives you an idea about how much he
was really concerned about his message
and how his message is being perceived
around the world after all during that
time period that's the only thing he has
bin laden had more than just satellite
tv to accompany him on his life on the
run he also had three of his wives and a
dozen of his kids and grandkids
looks like these are the grandkids
so this
my sense is that's the oldest the
grandson of osama bin laden he's
probably almost
10.
inside the compound there was a
different kind of osama bin laden and
depending on where you look bin laden
seems more like a doting grandfather
than a fanatical terrorist
[Music]
sesame street
so this is probably the kids we're
watching right but this is clearly
educational it's translated in arabic
yeah i mean it doesn't surprise me that
they would have been watching this i
think that's a terrible irony with bin
laden
the children can enjoy western products
and at the same time they could be
taught to hate the west
this contrast between light and dark
runs throughout these hard
drives there was warmth in
in abu dhabi's household
there were these poetry competitions
that his kids were reciting and bin
laden their grandfather
distributed prizes afterwards
but there was no escaping the fact that
the compound was no ordinary home more
like a minimum security prison
one of the most important security
measures is not to allow children to
leave the house
except
for
urgent necessities such as medical
treatments
they should not be allowed to be in the
yard unless they have an adult with them
to control their noise
[Music]
there was
physiological deprivation there was
isolation from other individuals
including other children there was
likely
no opportunity for these children to
have any kind of socialized experience
what what kids deserve and what they
need
[Music]
this boy looks bored with trying to play
in an environment of squalor
harley bin laden would take one of the
grandkids into the yard and show him how
to use a bb gun and shoot at birds and
capture this all on home video
seemingly in an effort to try and pass
the time
there's a bird in this
it tree like they shot it
out of the tree oh that's the bird that
was shot there they shot the bird seems
to be alive still
oh that's nothing
seems to be the grandson yeah
shot it in the head
now they're enjoying them
now they're indulging i should say
bin laden's obsession with a life of
violence and murder seemed to be
spreading to the children who were
living with him beyond the compound
walls his violent ideology was also
taking hold with horrific consequences
these are like child soldiers being
forced into combat
these files give us a road map into the
mind of a mass murderer
but they also illuminate how he sees the
imagination of so many disciples
so what about him inspired this devotion
when i met bin laden in 1997 i was
struck how the son of one of saudi
arabia's wealthiest families was living
this very modest life he had abandoned
luxury and he was living just like one
of his own foot soldiers
a lot of these guys who joined osama bin
laden and a lot of the qaeda members
being humble is something that they
didn't see in leaders where they came
from being humble is something that they
read in history books about the prophet
about the companions and osama bin laden
dressed like the prophet and the
companions and acted like the prophet
and the companions and for them
they saw humility
that they never seen
in this letter bin laden is suggesting
about how the jihadi leaders must
address
the public in their public statements
when they are presenting public
statements and it is important that the
spokesman
avoid being pompous or arrogant
it's interesting how important humility
is in the muslim character muslims are
taught that one of the worst sins is
arrogance so it is interesting to note
how humble bin laden
projected himself to be
but the hard drive data illuminates a
contradiction here
bin laden lived a very calculated life
fully aware that he was on stage at all
times
on screen he was a self-conscious
performer and the files show how hard he
worked to maintain his image
you can
read in some of the documents that
recovered in his house
that he was so much into his looks
on the compound he was
using hair dye to dye his beard to kind
of maintain a youthful appearance
despite his sort of humble affect he was
very conscious about his own image and
how he presented himself to the world
and ultimately he seemed like something
of a narcissist
narcissism is the felt quality of
perfection
one of the striking things about these
videos was the
videos where
he would make errors in his speech and
they would cut and then he would start
again he would often record multiple
takes of his speeches so he could get it
perfect
a quiet cue to cut
the narcissism is veiled
by a soft-spoken manner he recognized
that being humble
was actually very commanding for him
he was obsessed with his public image
the videos recovered from this compound
include many copies of documentaries and
new shows about bin laden that he seemed
to closely monitor
what do you make of osama bin laden's
statement today an audio tape from osama
bin laden osama bin laden osama bin
laden and do you know where i could find
a solid lot where in the world is osama
bin laden if we watch closely we can
even discern bin laden's tv viewing
habits he seemed to curate for himself
what he did and didn't want to see
a clue to this is how he watched tv news
footage if a female tv newscaster came
up on his tv take his remote and kind of
flip up the satellite channel find it so
it covered her face
and when she disappeared he would turn
it down and put it back onto a normal
screen
if there is other photos press
conference by president obama or
anything else
he press the menu button so he doesn't
want to see anything else but al-qaeda
and but himself
the hard drive contained a lot of videos
of extreme violence which bin laden may
well have been monitoring but many of
which are so violent that we can't even
show them to you
countless propaganda videos
many beheading videos
even the video of a young boy in iraq
beheading a hostage
a video of a group of kids kicking at
the dismembered leg of an american
soldier and celebrating chanting death
to america
it is robbing them of their innocence
these are like child soldiers being
forced into into combat
that is his mentality he was totally
blinded
by his war
bin laden did much more than simply
watch violence he was obsessed with
inflicting more of it on the world we
know based on the letters that the 9 11
attacks were not sufficient he wanted
something bigger and larger with
much more impact
[Music]
while bin laden was certainly on the run
he was trying to retain control of his
organization he was also trying to
recreate what he saw as his greatest
accomplishment 911. he thought that the
bigger of the attack the more the
americans would finally pull out of the
middle east the the american public
would start voting for people who would
have different foreign policy i think
that was a very naive view absolutely i
mean after 9 11 the united states got
more engaged in the middle east than
it's ever been in its history
[Music]
so it completely backfired
he's delusional
and he's a dreamer
what drove bin laden's hatred for the
united states in the west
i said and i have been not allah
allah
it's impossible to understand bin laden
without reference to his religious
beliefs this was a guy when he was a
teenager was praying seven times a day
fasting twice a week on the other hand
he was also a mass murderer
what was his relationship to religion
given how religious bin laden saw
himself it's not a surprise there's a
lot of religious material on these
drives
how great is allah
[Music]
he would often recite verses from the
quran in his letters
he would refer to sayings of the prophet
muhammad in his speeches
he thinks he's religious
he thinks he was doing the right thing
but he was not a religious authority
he was not a graduate of a seminary or
any kind of traditional religious
training
and so we have someone who's a
non-specialist making
unorthodox interpretations of the faith
because he actually starts by
acknowledging
that islam prohibits the killing of
non-combatants in warfare
but then goes on to explain in his mind
why
the political situation that we are
living in
allows him to violate that rule
what he did was to use political
justifications to violate a religious
edict
this homemade video found on the hard
drives begins as many of these al-qaeda
videos do by quoting a religious verse
with chanting in tandem and then the
message becomes clear
we hit the united states and we scared
them
then inevitably bin laden himself speaks
preaching to his followers
[Music]
and i think it's a really telling piece
of propaganda how it weaves together
religious imagery to superimpose them on
the tactics and actions of alcada
this homemade propaganda was crude but
tragically it was also effective he was
using religion as a tool
[Music]
does it mean to control people
to make people do whatever you want them
to do
and the end justify the meaning like any
any psychopath justify anything
i mean at one point he actually told his
commanders don't shy away from shedding
blood
you know if you look at the crusade do
you think christianity is a crusade no
the same thing it's people using
religion to obtain political goals
i think it's tragic that we let
a
criminal define the religion of 1.8
billion people
we would never
take the word of the kkk to define
christianity it would be ludicrous it
would be offensive
the quran is a recipe book and it called
for
a
tablespoon of sugar in the recipe
an extremist would read that and put a
cup of sugar instead so taking what the
quran says and taking it to
its extreme bin laden didn't do that
he read in the quran you need a
tablespoon of sugar and instead he put a
cup of cyanide
that's not an extremist that's a deviant
revisionist
bilan's view of his religion and
violence extended to his own family
terrorism was the family calling and he
was willing to sacrifice even those
closest to him for his self-styled holy
war
[Music]
bin laden fathered some 20 children
throughout his life
a half dozen were with him in the
abadabad compound along with another
half dozen grandchildren
he was also accompanied by two of his
four wives
one of which had a surprising role on
the compound the very first letter that
i write from the cia's declassification
is actually by his wife siham
the first thing that she writes with
daughter i write you in haste because
i'm really busy with your father
preparing his public statements
and saham wasn't the only wife who was
helping with less than a year left to
live bin laden was joined by the oldest
of his four wives korea
also known as zoom hamsa
his letter to heidi when she was still
in northwestern this is the oldest wife
the oldest wife in in that letter he
says something to the effect that i sent
the brother on your end money to buy you
a computer and i'm also sending you
everything that i've got on my computer
to help us
with writing the public statement for
the anniversary of 9 11. so he was
asking her to review his statements and
and send me any ideas that you have so
that indicates
that
omaha was
in a way his wordsmith
he needed her for the message
so yes it is surprising
that
many of those public statements that bin
laden delivered to the world were
actually written or at least co-authored
by his wife
you don't see that with
other
terrorist leaders there was definitely
some level of respect there
bin laden was looking for guidance and
at the same time that he was getting
help from his wives to write his
speeches he was also heavily influencing
the kids who were living on the compound
[Music]
foreign
i mean it's clear that
he's being indoctrinated at such a young
age
in this way and and it's extremely
heartbreaking
god it's
it's a scary but that's just another
indication that you know
for osama bin laden
the only thing that matters is the cause
he's recording this video in front of
the same wall as bin laden
what makes them happier than
this kid memorizing
a poem about jihad and about war
to make bin laden happy
i absolutely see
this young man as a victim this child
and along with probably everyone else in
the compound we see in that video a
young boy reciting a poem as a jihadist
warrior and then we also see that boy
smiling at somebody off camera and that
tells me
that it was likely that he was receiving
at least nonverbal praise from whoever
was off camera as he did that
[Music]
as the walls began to close in on bin
laden his paranoia began to extend even
to his own family
i was told that you went to a dentist in
iran and you were concerned about a
filling she had put in for you bin laden
was concerned about one of his wives who
was under house arrest in iran for a
long period of time
that she might have a tracking device
planted in her teeth by the iranians
the size of the chip is about the length
of a grain of wheat and the width of a
fine piece of vermicelli
[Music]
this was a really high level of paranoia
but of course he had reasons to be
paranoid he was the world's most wanted
man
and on top of the paranoia the safe
space that bin laden had built was
starting to crumble
in the final months when he was alive
the two bodyguards who were his only
conduit to the outside world were
beginning to turn on him sadly i came to
realize that they have reached the level
of exhaustion that they are shutting
down and they ask to leave us all
there's an irony here which is bin laden
is the leader of this global terrorist
organization
and yet it looked like he was going to
lose the two bodyguards that were his
main connection to the outside world
day by day bin laden's world began to
constrict
the walls were closing in around him
this particular paranoid did have real
enemies and those enemies were slowly
drawing near
so he was even planning to move
apparently to a different location
and the navy seal still came down
but who really was the man behind those
walls the drives could only tell me so
much
my journey started with an interview and
now it needs to end with two more with
two men who can give us a whole new
perspective on what we found on these
hard drives
osama what the hell what happened to him
become like that
warrior
leader
actor
family man
mass murderer osama bin laden like his
hard drives contain multitudes
a forensic search for the real osama bin
laden by sifting through his words
images and home videos can only get us
so far
now i want to take it a step further and
discuss what we found with two men who
knew him well
abdullah nas fought side by side with
bin laden in afghanistan was one of his
closest friends in the 1980s
and abdul bariatwan is the only
journalist who has spent days with bin
laden
at his mountain stronghold
what was your impression of him as a
person to be honest as a person he
impressed me he was
modest by nature he wasn't actually
acting for it to to impress me what was
he like
ordinary guy for me i recognized many
positive sides of of osama which is
he talks less he he know he knows what
to say he knows how to say it but
he's humble
so what was osama like with his family
usama it's someone you feel it's close
to his
sons
his children
in the computer what we found
is that the two wives the two older
wives were helping him with his speeches
so you surprised by that they were uh
schoolers they were highly educated they
got phd yeah so and they believed on him
so i wouldn't be surprised if they
actually helped him
what was
osama's relationship with religion
with faith or with religion
both
you can maybe sometime find someone
faithful
less religious
someone completely religious but not
faithful
the most important to be faithful yeah
when you are faithful
let alone you are muslim or non-muslim
the faith
lead you to the honesty
lead you to be peaceful
usama
still remembers some moment of
his faith
what the hell what happened to him
become like that
i don't know
i don't know
sometimes that's the only answer
he's a strange combination of things
because he's this modest retiring humble
soft-spoken guy yet you know he's
killing thousands of people civilians
so what is that
complicated yeah
to be honest it never occurred to me
this man actually will be the most
dangerous wanted man on earth and i
don't believe he wanted to be that
[Music]
this is one of
bin laden's grandsons
[Music]
[Music]
you know the conclusion i reached i
reached now
the main challenge is
not to make
these generations
ready
for a fight
to be martyred to be martyred
so it's easy to recruit somebody to
become a modder what the harder thing is
the harder part
teach him how to build
peaceful society
so what's bin laden's legacy
it's a lot of violence and kind of
meaningless violence
he also blew up his own family a number
of his children have been killed in the
year since 9 11.
many of his associates are dead or in
prison or have disappeared
certainly hasn't created a more safe
world or more stable middle east
i think his legacy is a legacy of death
the legacy of destruction
leaving a trail of broken lives
and today
al-qaeda has
way more people who adhere to the
philosophy and the ideology and the
narrative of osama bin laden that they
had on 9 11.
i believe isis is part of the bin
ladenism
and the navy seals took down the
messenger
but the message still lives
on the other hand bin laden's ideas have
been firmly rejected by 99.9 of muslims
around the world
when you look into what's happening in
the arab spring you don't see al-qaeda
flag you don't see bin laden's photo you
see people who want democracy you know
who hate democracy you see people who
want freedom you know who hate freedom
in the political sense
osama bin laden
he sent a lot of other people to their
deaths he didn't die a heroic holy
warrior on the front lines
he ended up in a pretty comfortable
compound surrounded by his wife and
family
kind of ended with a whimper as opposed
to a bang
osama bin laden's digital files left
behind an imprint and we're left to
determine the meaning
how do you feel about him now
i think he will end up as a footnote in
history he was a complex personality i
absolutely feel that bin laden hurt
muslims you have to hold this
quiet respectful manner to other people
at the same time that he was a global
terrorist osama bin laden is not the
first one of history who declared war
against
the established orders of the time and
he won't be the last when you come to
responsibility when you come to the
blood of innocent there is no gray area
even you are my friend i still remember
you are humble you are nice you are
honest
that all will go when you commit one
drop of innocent blood
bin laden is one of the few people you
can say change the course of history
but he did not leave the world a better
place
and he'll be remembered for that
[Music]
so
[Music]
you